try never to even mention Dylan Mulvaney
I don't even like the fact that I
mentioned it or sorry I brought him up
no no no that's fine but the the the
problem is then that that is a failure
the obsession with drag shows Etc it's a
failure to morally triage or even
socially and politically triage the
problems we have like Portland Oregon
Portland Oregon is becoming a huge
Cesspool homelessness drug addiction uh
crime on a national level we have
inflation we have problems to Ukraine
war we should simply not be talking
about Dylan Mulvaney it's it's insane
you know Douglas Mario our mutual friend
says it's like it you know people are
trying to sneak nukes in and everybody's
worried about everybody's pronouns